[Music]
again we're going to do 10 minute okay
here we go 2263 slamka good luck all
right so as we've already established
I'm playing my main repertoire and we're
facing C3 so in the previous alipin game
which I which we played I think I went
for D6 I think I went for D6 but here
I'm going to go for my main my sort of
official black recommendation against
the alipin which is D5 and Knight F6
which our opponent I guess was not
expecting because he pre moved D4 here
the move is C takes D4 and our opponent
is immediately funneling the game into
what structure what is the structure
that our opponent funnels the game into
it is the I iqp it's the iqp isolated
Queen Pawn now is it a good version for
white not particularly because we
already have a blockading knight on T5
which is the kind of dream scenario so
it's an iqp but it's a it's a really
good version for black as we continue to
develop because we have this blockading
Knight on D5 is black much better No in
fact after Knight C3 this is likely to
transpose into Mainline caroon Theory
but nonetheless it's a pleasant
position okay so Bishop G4 would
transpose into a very well known line of
the caroon where white plays Queen B3
and the situation liquidates into an
equal end game so we could play Bishop
G4 of course after Bishop G4 we also
could meet Bishop E2 we could play
E6 in order to keep more pieces on the
board we could even play G6 um which is
also entirely
possible let me think about
this G6 I don't know much about this
move actually yeah Bishop G4 is theory
E6 is possible I'm going to go E6 I'm
going to try to keep the purity of the
iqp I'm going to go E6 just to avoid the
drawish line Bishop G4 Queen B3 is not a
forced draw but it's a forced exchange
of a lot of pieces and it's a drawish
resulting end game so we're going to
continue our kingside development Bishop
B7 and uh we can Castle so we have
completed our kingside development the
only issue if you can call it that is
the bishop on C8 and typically in iqp
structures it is fan kod on B7 now one
very weird thing that you might see
first of all white can play Knight takes
D5 at any moment he doesn't one very
weird thing that you will see in a lot
of iqp games is this move Knight D5 back
to F6 why is this move weird well
because isn't the whole point you might
be wondering of the of playing against
the iqp to blockade the pawn and it's a
little bit hard for me to explain during
the game so I'll give you some more
logic after the game but the basic idea
is the D4 Pawn shouldn't only be
blockaded it should also be attacked um
and in the name of attacking it we can
play a move that's even more aggressive
than Knight F6 opening up an attack on
the pawn but also hitting another piece
what are we talking about here it's a
risky move but I like it I like this
move it's the move Knight D to B4 which
has to be seriously contemplated Knight
D to B4 it's a risky move but Knight F6
is the safe option and Knight F6 is is
the move that that's more text Booky
kind of it's more text
Booky okay let's give it a shot let's
give it a shot no Greek gift sacrifice
because G5 is protected we have a bishop
here so there will never be any kind of
GRE gift now what am I trying to do with
this move well first of all I'm
attacking the D4 Pawn but I'm also
trying to go after the light squ Bishop
why is it important to go after the
light squ Bishop because this is the
main vehicle the main tool that white
uses in initiating the kingside attack
and in iqp structures White's bread is
buttered on the king side if we can
eliminate this bishop we eliminate the
possibility of a battery against the H7
Pawn which means that we can keep our
Pawn structure entirely intact which
means that White's attack is not going
to get off the ground without this
bishop so white now has to decide
between giving this bishop away big
positional concession or giving away the
iqp which is obviously risky from
White's point of view as well as ours um
so that's that's the basic logic here
this is why in iqp structures you will
often see white playing the move A3
sooner rather than later and it's
partially to avoid this Knight B4 Knight
Sally okay so let's see what is our
opponent's response and it's Bishop I
think this is the best move well as the
expression goes having said a we have to
say b or do we as some of you are
pointing out we can play Knight takes D4
and we get into this incredibly complex
position where the queen can get kind of
tossed
around it's a little bit iffy if you ask
me but we can also throw in a really
nice little move to chase this bishop
away and to pose white with another
dilemma and I'm talking about the move
F5 and you might look at this move and
you say well I get it we want to go
after this bishop but aren't we very
seriously weakening the E6 Pawn we are
right there's no arguing with that but
if white trades on C6 then white will
not be able to attack it effectively and
it's going to be nicely protected by the
Light skirt Bishop yes the E6 Pawn is
now a drawback of our position but as
you get higher and higher rated you need
to move away from this way of thinking
where you kind of Reason categorically
like oh this move contains a drawback
therefore I'm not going to play it
that's the kind of reasoning that's
going to limit you and prevent your
progression a lot of times you need to
make a move that yes it has a drawback
but it strengths out way its drawbacks
and this I think is the case with F5
okay so we can play BC in order to
really you know increase our blockade on
D5 but I'm not really worried about
white pushing the pawn just yet or am I
BC is a very serious idea by the way
so much so that I'm leaning in the
direction of BC I'm leaning in yeah
let's go BC let's go BC um it also
insinuates Bishop A6 although that's not
a threat as you should see because Queen
takes E6 as a check Bishop A6 is not a
threat but it might be in the long run
like once that we protect this pawn
bishop A6 might become a possibility now
our Pawn structure is bad there's no
denying that but we have compensatory
factors we have the bishop
we have now a complete blockade over the
iqp which will remain a weakness for the
foreseeable future um and we have the
prospect of getting this bishop out to
an active
Square okay three obviously we go Knight
D5 so again make sure that you
understand Bishop A6 runs into Queen
takes E6 check we have no choice but to
come back to the blockading square let's
see what our opponent comes up with here
Queen C4 okay it's not a very scary move
um it hits the C6 Pawn so we definitely
would like to defend this Pawn what are
what is on the menu here well we can
defend it with the bishop Bishop B7 but
I would like to avoid Bishop B7 if
possible because not only does it put
the bishop on a closed diagonal but the
E6 Pawn can then be targeted with a move
like Rook E1 so I'd like to defend this
Pawn with a queen and by playing Queen
B6 the additional benefit is that Bishop
A6 now is a threat so it's it's both
both an attacking move and a defensive
move Bishop queen queen B6 is an
no-brainer and should be should be too
should be an no-brainer too um now
Bishop A6 is an actual threat it wins
material so white should play Rook E1
but that doesn't mean we won't play
Bishop A6 we we'll consider that move
anyway but notice that the bishop on C8
is not a terrible piece because it is
guarding the very important Pawn on E6
the saying goes I think it was coined by
this Romanian Grandmaster the bad
Bishops defend good pawns sometimes bad
Bishops defend bad pawns but sometimes
bad pawns can be very important to the
health of your position Rook E1 good job
by our opponent so Bishop A6 hits the
Queen the queen doesn't have a lot of
squares but it does have A2 which is
quite annoying and then we're going to
have to deal with the E6 Pawn again so I
would prefer to make a different
improving move what's available to us
what pieces can we can we improve well
looking around the board um I'm looking
at the bishop on E7 and I'm noticing
that we can position it on F6 in order
to increase the pressure on D4 and also
getting the bishop out of the rook's
X-ray I don't like Bishop D7 because it
runs into Knight E5 and the bishop on D7
looks hella awkward um so let's go
Bishop F6 just keeping the tension and
this is the last game I'm I'm uh I'm
running on fumes here for those watching
on YouTube this is six and a half our
stream now um but this is the final game
so enjoy it while it
lasts Knight A4 clearly our opponent is
going to C5 but what squares are given
up by the Knight when it moves from C3
to A4 well the B5 Square I think is the
juiciest one that we can sync our Queen
onto it's a juicy move because if the
Queens are traded then we correct our
Pawn structure our pawns visit the
orthodontist and um we can then protect
the E6 Pawn with Rook E8 I think black
has the edge in the end game after the
trade after the trade I think black has
the edge a very mature move is Queen C2
that's what I would play but slamka
trades and hits the pawn on E6 which we
should defend should we defend it
perhaps with our King maybe but again
that runs into 95 check um I think that
we should defend it with our Rook I
think we should defend it with our Rook
I would also at this point consider
sacrificing the pawn to free up our
other pieces but I think it's a little
bit early for that I think it's a little
early for that I don't see a drawback to
the move Rook E8 and we are cramped here
because of this Knight on C5 but we're
going to try to find ways to work around
it and we're going to try to find ways
to continue improving our position even
though this Knight is hanging over our
position like the sword of dam I like
Black's position here even though it may
not look appealing to you Bishop D2
okay man I would kill to put a bishop on
B7 but we can't do that just yet hm
here's what I want to do I would like to
activate the A8 rook and we can do it
through B8 we can do it through B8 and
then B6 and the additional benefit of
that is well there's two first of all
when we get the Rook to B6 we're
overprotecting the E6 pawn and second of
all maybe later on we can push B4 and
open up the queen side a little bit so
it's a good multi-purpose move now I
amend my assessment I think the position
is equal I think the position is equal
but the situation gets to uh time
pressure phase now Rook e two so our
opponent clearly piling up on the pawn
well that's even more of a reason for us
to play Rook B6 but we don't necessarily
have to rush with that move and one
alternate way that we can actually
defend is we can play the move H6 to
prevent various Knight G5 Shenanigans
and then we could play King F7 but then
again it runs into Knight E5 and what
I'm trying to avoid is an opposite
colored Bishop end game I'm trying to
avoid the trade on E5 because that
position would be a little bit too D for
my taste I think that position would be
very close to a draw um so yeah so let's
go Rook B6 over protecting the pawn
let's not do that yeah let's not draw
let's try to win but if white plays well
this is a draw I don't think that we can
win this position against best play um I
was also dealing with Bishop A5 for a
while but Bishop A5 I think we go Rook
D6 okay H4 we're quickly going to go
H6 um to protect the G5 square and I'm
playing this move without thinking
because clearly it it keeps the status
quo it keeps the status quo um The Rook
from B6 does not have to move to C6 it
can also move over to
D6 um closer to the center and
everything's nicely protected here good
position for
black yeah of course white can play H5
but remember if white pushes the pawn to
H5 that's a long-term weakness like you
never know when in some night end game
we'll be able to pick that pawn off so
it's a very committal move Rook A1 yeah
I have to commend our opponent he's
playing very high quality chess I think
this is a really good game in general by
by both of us so far okay so we're going
to complete the Rook lift with Rook D6
we're going to complete the Rook lift
and another reason I'm putting the Rook
on D6 is I'm trying to preempt the move
Knight E5 now if white plays Knight E5
the D4 Pawn
is going to be x-rayed and we can
potentially drop our Knight back and hit
the pawn directly G3 okay now we really
really need to find a way to to work
around this Knight let me think about
this I'm liking the look of Knight B6
actually sort of maybe it's time to play
King F7 and bite the bullet I think it
is I think we should go King F7 and this
is not a draw offer by the way I think
that the situation has subtly changed
after knight5 check and I actually think
that black in the resulting position has
some meat on the bone there after kn5
check which I'm expecting I think Knight
E5 is pretty much automatic we're also
keeping Ane an eye on the clock Knight
D3 okay but that is a huge concession I
think our opponent is leading the Knight
to E5 but finally the Embargo the
Embargo has been lifted at last and we
do not need to be asked twice let's get
this bishop out to B7
completing our development and if white
says okay never mind let's go back to C5
no no no we're not going to go back to
C8 we're going to go back to A8 and
that's partially why we played King F7
okay so here there's no need to take the
Knight we just drop back and now we're
starting to outplay our opponent okay
yeah yeah I'll I'll bend I'll bend the
guy okay Knight C5 and there we go we're
not going Bishop C8 and and and
forgiving white for you know this untour
move we're going to go Bishop A8 and now
our Bishop is very smugly sitting on the
long diagonal Bishop C3 okay the next
stage is to start directly attacking
some of White's weaknesses here we can
also expand on the king side with G5
which is a really attractive idea to me
actually I like the look of G5 I'm
actually thinking about Checkmate
already I'm thinking about Checkmate I
know that sounds crazy but if white
trades on G5 I think White's King might
be in very big
trouble uh in the long run
here Knight D7 okay I didn't see that
move but what does it do oh it hits E6
like this okay so we should definitely
protect E6 we should go we should go
King F7 here which is also part of the
plan so King F7 is a move that I would
have played anywhere or King G7 does
anybody see what I'm trying to set up
here with this bishop yeah endgame
Checkmate Rook h8 potentially
now it might be time for us to
take um let me think there's some
calculation already to do no let's go
King G7 and let's try to set up some
tactics already oh my gosh oh there's
something juicy here there's some juicy
tactics let's go for some juicy tactics
shall we let's go here F3 instantly okay
that was a good move okay so now we go
that was a mistake by me actually juicy
tactics was wrong
let's go here oh my gosh I need to move
I missplay oh my gosh I
blundered oh my gosh I blundered very
badly right just now okay now I got to
try to flag
him man I just I just spoiled would have
been an amazing
game oh my gosh very impressive time
scrambling by our
opponent yeah um not the way that we
wanted to end this game but this is what
nitzki does oh my gosh what a game
honestly what a game that was Insanity I
saw this made from a distance actually
um sorry I had to go into cheat code
cheat mode I got too excited about the
the mate prospects and I didn't
calculate properly I feel like I was
maybe even winning at the end yeah I
definitely
missed um missed a win
somewhere
oh okay the move was um first of all the
move was Knight C3 but uh the move here
was to play Let's Start From The End
incredible game song mean you were
winning at the end so I I only won due
to the clock uh Knight C3 BC and now um
if Rook h8 the problem is that white has
this very annoying move F3 okay this is
what you have to understand and after
Bishop F3 Rook E6 Rook H1 is no longer
Checkmate so the classic Motif here is
to essentially sit on White's position
you can't allow the F Pawn to move so
the correct move that I missed is Bishop
F3 I didn't see this at all Bishop F3
and if Rook E3 you secure the bishop
with G4 and ultimately white is going to
have to give the Rook up for the
bishop so Rook h8 is threatened here and
there's very little that that can be
done about this Knight E6 check you can
play D takes E6 oh this is beautiful and
Rook h8 amazing oh and look at this line
so there's a m threat on H1 right and
white can play Rook E7
check and after you take suddenly it
turns out the black's King doesn't have
too many squares because if you go back
to G8 you allow the trade and white is
winning you have to go up to G6 white
goes Knight E5 check King F6 hitting the
Rook Rook F7 King E6 and black wins
because now white finally has to take
the bishop and drops the exchange I mean
these lines would would have been crazy
so I just missed the moment to play
Knight takes C3 um Rook h8 was wrong and
here I should have played Knight C3 BC
and either Bishop takes F3 or something
like Bishop D5 just solidifying the pawn
and black is still better but I I
panicked I panicked and I played Knight
B6 completely forgetting that that the
bishop can be captured cut me some slack
it's been seven hours
so yeah here King F6 D5 and the game is
over because the Rook is lost now let's
start from the start now let's start
from the
start so I'm not sure if sluma expected
Queen takes D5 or D4 is his move against
everything but in any case I can refer
you to the earlier speedrun videos where
this move is analyzed extensively I'm
not going to delve too deeply into the
into the variations here I've done the
several several times uh D4 CD4 CD4 is a
possible line it's not a it's not a an
ambitious variation like black equalizes
easily but it is a solid option uh for
white it's not it's not like black is
better here it's not like black is
better here so just to clarify what I
was referring to after Knight C3 Bishop
G4 um does anybody know what White's
main move is and I mentioned this during
the game let's see who was paying
attention
now this position typically arises out
of the
caroon um E4 C6 D4 D5 the pawn of attack
and you usually get this position like
this bishop G4 CD Knight D5 what is the
move what is the move yeah it's Queen B3
now Bishop F3 GF E6 Queen B7 I'm going
to make these moves quickly because this
is all Theory and now there's Queen C6
and queen takes B5 but the bottom line
is that you get this you get this end
game and it's not like it's a force draw
there are some imbalances but it's a
very very hard position to win if white
knows what what they're doing uh so
that's the reason why I avoided the
natural Bishop G4 and decided to play
E6 G6 is also possible but again Queen
B3 is a little bit unpleasant this hits
the Knight and black is not in time to
stabilize the Knight on on D5 so that's
why I decided to play E6 okay Bishop D3
Bishop B7 castles castles Queen E2 and
now the position gets very interesting
because I made a unconventional decision
to play Knight D to B4 the typical way
that you are recommended to play this
position with black is to complete your
development as quickly as you can with
B6 the problem is that if you play B6
immediately you are allowing Knight
takes D5 with I think a very small
Advantage for white because Queen takes
D5 runs into the unpleasant Bishop
E4 so that is mostly why people often
drop the Knight back to F6 first and
then play B6 and then Bishop B7 and
later they reestablish a knight on on D5
if that if that kind of makes General
sense uh so for example if white plays
Rook D1 to protect the pawn black can
play B6 um white can play A3 Bishop B7
and you get sort of a very typical iqp
struggle very typical iqp struggle I
could spend like two hours talking about
the typical plans for both sides but
it's really really late and I'm feeling
super tired so instead we're going to
focus on the course of the game we're
going to focus on Knight to B4 what I'll
say is that if white wants to avoid this
kind of stuff then it's worth playing a
move like A3 and then we would have
dropped the Knight back to F6 you might
be wondering can black take on C3 and
the answer is yes this leads to What's
called the hanging Pond structure which
is a completely different kettle of fish
I like this less than playing against
the iqp so I tend not to take on C3 but
it is also possible to do that so
anyways Knight B4 Bishop E4 good move I
think the only principled move why did
Knight take on D4 in this position I was
worried that our Queen is going to get
tossed around and I was worried that
White's control over the defile is going
to hamper the development of our Bishop
also notice Queen E5 runs into Bishop H7
Queen B6 runs into Bishop B3 another
Tempo move and Bishop C5 walks into
Knight A4 with a fork so I just
evaluated this intuitively I didn't
calculate pass Rook D1 the computer
believes that what does the computer
believe the computer believes that I'm
going to turn it on just a
second just a moment my computer's
Frozen there we go so the evaluation
here is plus equals yeah white is better
Queen
F6 white is modestly better it's not
like white is winning here but by any
means the best move for white
is to play Bishop E3 just Bishop E3
completing development and then Bishop
D4 White's got a big initiative this
should make sense too this is why we
decided to start with F5 now after F5 if
the bishop had dropped all the way back
to B1 now it's a different story now you
can take on D4 this is a much improved
version because the bishop is super
passive it's biting on granite and The
Rook or the queen has a very nice spot
on F6 that's safe from attacks because
E4 is protected so these are the subtle
differences that make up high level
chests right so Knight takes D4 here is
too risky but after you throw an F5 it's
already possible so I think the decision
to play Bishop C6 was a good one the
computer does not like BC by the way and
believes white is clearly better here so
maybe Knight takes C6 was a better move
but I kind of like this move I I like
the way that we played here I feel like
this gives pretty good practical chances
A3 Knight C5 Queen C4 and queen B6
defending and threatening Bishop A6 Rook
e won Bishop F6 we get our pieces to
good squares white plays Knight A4 which
is the best move and the computer still
believes that white is much better here
actually which is really interesting
Queen B5 but here slamka makes a big
mistake after the trade the position is
equal so this makes all the difference
what should white have done what should
white have done who can tell
me what should white have done here yeah
Queen C2 now why is Black's position bad
well it has to do primarily with the
fact that this bishop does not have a
future and the fact that E6 is a very
weak Pawn I think I underestimated those
factors and also that black has a very
hard time making a move White's next
move is going to be Knight C5 against
almost anything and black just doesn't
have an active plan so while Black's
position is solid black has no way to
continue improving the engine's top move
is H6 and by the way the engine's top
move for white is H3 and now A5 so you
get this like Pawn Play Because black
just doesn't have any better moves and
now White's just going to continue
loading up the pieces in the center
Bishop D2 Rook D1 Knight E5 I mean it's
it's pretty clear that black is in some
trouble here two many weaknesses not
enough active pieces and no active plan
for
black so Queen C2 would have been a very
nasty move and this is why according to
the engine I should have played Knight
takes C6 so BC was was overzealous white
is slightly better here after Rook D1
but after something like knight uh
Bishop D6 or Knight B4 to prevent D5
black position remains very much
table but maybe this entire operation
with Knight B4 was UN not worth it maybe
I should have just gone with the normal
Knight
F6 so anyways we get into the end game
and in the end game we first protect the
pawn on E6 then we were able to deploy
The Rook Rook
B8 and bring it to B6 then we played H6
to cover the G5 Square so all of our
moves I think in the end game make a lot
of sense G3 we bring the king up what
was the moment at which black started
taking over the initiative I think it
was Knight D3 I think Knight D3 was a
frustration move by slamka uh because it
allowed us to bring our Bishop out and
then we reached ideal peace coordination
so a lot of people have a hard time
doing nothing but sometimes you have to
like in a position like this if I was
playing hikaro with white I would
literally just go Rook C1 Rook E1 Rook
C1 black has no way to make progress
here as long as the Knight remains on C5
Bishop D7 by the way runs into Knight E5
check very important detail and the
bishop is
lost so Knight D3 was a frustration move
the E5 square is not worth it and once
the bishop got to the long diagonal and
we expanded now black is already taking
over the
advantage then another Tempo was wasted
and here we had the win with Knight C3
and Bishop F3 this is where I panicked
um first I played Rook h
hoping for Knight takes C6 Rook e 6 Rook
e 6 Knight C3 with M on H1 and black is
winning so this was hope chess slamka
found F3 and now more hope chess why did
I play Knight B6 so I was aiming for
this position I was aiming for this
position which isn't even that good but
I was hoping that the Knight on E6 would
be stranded somehow it was just a
Mindless Mindless move and time pressure
and obviously after Knight F6 black can
resign
actually here I had rookie one oh my
gosh here I could have just taken and
taken so this was not even not even a
good move now of course here G4 is the
easiest way to win preventing G4 mate um
so that's that's the basic idea slamka
would would have won you were one move
away incredibly played played game so
this was a bit of a weird game I feel
like I'm I'm running out of gas because
it's really late but the basic idea is
that we got the iqp structure in the iqp
structure you're trying to blockade the
square in front of the pawn and then
complete your development by Fen ketoing
the bishop but we decided to go for this
interesting strategy trying to eliminate
the bishop note that the iqp can be
effectively sacrificed but we didn't
take it then we got this very
interesting structure that I thought was
a lot better than it was Salam played
very well but allowed the bishop to come
out and allowed us to rectify the pawn
structure I was was able to outplay him
in the end game but then ultimately time
pressure caused panic and that caused
the quality of play to deteriorate so
that's where where I'm going to end for
now guys um sorry I'm exhausted I'm
going to go sleep um this was a seven
hour stream tons of Blitz tons of
speedruns I think this was awesome
remember if you like what I do you could
subscribe to my YouTube so thanks
everybody for hanging out okay I can
barely talk I'm exhausted um sluma good
game
uh and I'll see you guys
[Music]
later